well after the movie came out I was a
World Tour I um DJ for Tyler or whatever
I miss DJ so we did uh America
Australia we did like the UK and Europe
and all that stuff and that was a blast
tour is always fun sir so when you're on
tour with Tyler it's just straight Arena
Rock I like yeah this um I'm about to
cut you off with it I'm awful yeah this
tour was uh Arenas
smack the mic you know as his career
gets higher the um Arenas get bigger and
it's pretty crazy the shows are like
he's an amazing performer he's really
good there's a lot of the rap people
don't know how to perform that well
nowadays they just like kind of play the
track and like dance on stage but like
he performed just like actual performer
for real so that's always cool to see
the homies do they think how many shows
did you guys do on the world tour that's
a good question because I don't be
paying attention um it was a nice amount
it was for sure like
I was gonna guess in between 40 and 60.
oh [__] because it was like we hit like
all the like popular states in
California I mean California in America
and all the cooler places in Europe and
then we did uh
uh both of the coasters of Australia and
then we never made it back to Japan I
thought we was going back to Japan this
tour but I guess that didn't happen but
maybe next time give a favorite place
um like in the states or out of States
out of States out of States it's hard to
just pick one but I can name a couple
places I love to go I like London a lot
I like Copenhagen
um Japan was really really cool
honestly everywhere I love Australia
great times out there I can't even say
like it's nowhere I really been I like
hate it but I got a question when you're
touring with Tyler
um is it with the whole Odd Future as a
collective or is odd future still a
thing
um or is it just Tyler it's just him
yeah well at first it was um I was just
hype man Travis Taco was DJ and he will
perform but then Travis started doing
more stuff with um with movies and
television and stuff like that so then I
started becoming a DJ so now it's just
me and him on tour plus you know all the
production and all that stuff but yeah
sweet
and uh the straight Arena rocking yeah
how old are you 32 all right so like I
don't really care to go out I rather
drink at home if I do drink but I don't
have a drink like that no more I have to
relax I'm a relaxer
I'm like 32. is that higher or lower
than your body count
I think that's a good question my body
count for sure is higher than that I was
a wild man in them first tours
I can only imagine when I first tested
the uh the groupie thing that was crazy
I was like I see I literally tested it
it was a girl if you want to go on a
tour bus and take photos and I was like
you want to come on the bus like what's
up and she was like I'll suck your dick
and I was like let's see what happens
and I was like it's that easy and Tori
became a [__] you know a party
that's crazy it's dangerous though you
never know that's crazy like uh it
didn't how long did that like kind of a
Vibe regardless because you seem like
the such a chill dude like you're not
really
um I was a wild man for a while I was
like the first like seven years of uh
the uh the fame whatever you want to
call it being noticed by the word I
would say I like to use the word famous
because I don't feel like I'm really
famous I'm just a young black man living
a nice life yeah I think that's that's
fair to say like uh I I think I don't
like to use the word famous too much
because I don't think I'm that big
LeBron James is famous right you know
what I'm saying I'm Jasper
how are you neither touring around uh on
a bus or taking PJs in America's on a
bus and then uh it was PJs and regular
flights in Europe I usually uh we'll
stay like for instance like we'll stay
in London for a little while and then
fly to the other parts in your shows and
then come back and like that'll be our
Hub like our stay spot that's cool you
guys sell a ton of merch at your shows
yeah the emergency go crazy I did my
Merchant here a little bit
that's good yeah and we'll be taking
over next time it's that Jasper Dolphin
merch at the shows no it's uh the brand
is called last call I started a while
ago it's not like Jasper Dolphin but
it's just different cool designs and and
when you're on tour like you're you're
just raking in money I mean those shows
are huge yeah yeah straight work it's a
it's good work because it's like it's
not too hard it's fun I'm there with my
friends like security guards like one of
my good friends too we love veal he's
the greatest security guard he might
look scary but he's a nice man
all right it was off it's all fun fun
and games
and you guys travel on one bus you and
Tyler
um this recent tour yeah it was just me
and him on the bus and then I think we
had a couple of buses because the tours
are like you know the Productions
everything way bigger than it used to be
so it felt weird it was just me and him
on the book usually it'd be like me him
one of the other homies somebody that
records like video and like security but
security got his own bus now with some
other people so it was different it's
cool it's crazy man do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butt wall are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude